it's great to welcome back to the
program today Steve Almond who's the
author of The New York Times bestsellers
candy freak and against football the new
novel is called all the secrets of the
world and you can find him on Twitter at
Steve Almond Joy uh Steve great to have
you back on today yeah good to be with
you David so we reviewed in the
aftermath of this horrible incident that
took place on the NFL field with Demar
Hamlin your appearance with Fox News
host Laura Ingram where uh you pointed
out some of uh the things she has
previously said on her program which she
didn't particularly like and you there
was so much that took place in that
interview and I know many in our
audience really appreciated it so let's
just start at something very very top
level what happened with Demar Hamlin
was very visible in the sense that it
happened at a very particular moment in
a game he suffered a cardiac arrest
during a game and that makes it a much
more interesting media story because it
has a sort of beginning a middle and
presumably some end where he's now been
released from the hospital and so on and
so forth the the truth is and you've
been writing about how there's a much
slower motion story that afflicts many
other players that doesn't lend itself
to this beginning middle end of hey it
happened during the game which is the
brain injury and the cumulative effect
of football talk a little bit about how
the media reaction is so dramatically
different to what took place on the
field over a week ago versus that bigger
story
yeah it's kind of crazy like you saw in
the appearance with Ingram I basically
said hey you know there is there are
these big media events that you know the
reason I'm even snuck onto your fascist
network is because you know somebody
let's find a libtard who hates football
it's that kind of uh zero-sum thinking
propaganda thinking yeah and I try to
sort of calmly say to her you know the
NFL's own actuaries did admit that 30 of
their players are going to wind up with
brain damage because of the accretion of
these sub-concussive events invisible
inside the helmet thousands of them
absorbed over a career and literally
they cause brain damage in this major
American workplace and you sort of said
it before her like what if 30 percent of
Fox News were getting brain damage I
think actually they're giving brain
damage right what if by by Design but I
think what if this was in another
American workplace and just try to set
out for her the the Monstrous double
standard that applies when when it comes
to football that there's this workplace
where literally a third of the employees
are going to get and it's just crickets
it's like no reaction to that at all and
it's because and I think that's actually
writ large the media's general reaction
it's a complicated story it's a story
that's happening out of view and in fact
the NFL paying off that lawsuit
settling it is precisely what the NFL
wanted to happen their nightmare is
junior seau's family or Michael Webb
Mike Webster's family or any of these
guys even Tony Dorsett
um you know famous players and their
families talking about what it's like to
live with CTE they just want none of
that in the public eye and their content
I think in a sense with the Demar Hamlin
time you know story because that is is
you point out that's going to be very
satisfying he's getting better the
medical you know he was he recovered and
God thank God he's getting better but
let's step back and say literally for
every Demar Hamlin there is another
player who is in his 40s or 50s or 60s
who doesn't know where he is who doesn't
recognize his family anymore who
suffered permanent cognitive decline in
brain damage and that's happening out of
you and I think that's kind of the deal
that Americans make if I can't see it
really in a sense what's fascinating to
me David we're a lot of businesses are
in the empty empathy suppression
business and that's what the NFL is in
it's in the empathy suppression and
their players have to suppress their
empathy but also by implication the fans
also have to suppress their empathy they
have to really occlude their moral
imagination so that they cannot imagine
that scenario and that's how I think we
continue to be able to consume stuff
that's really destructive whether it's a
football game or a hamburger whatever it
is we ignore the slaughterhouse and we
like take a big bite of the bacon
cheeseburger that's kind of the big deal
of American capitalism and when you try
to connect those dots and say I know you
can't see it I know that in your fragile
mindset we're hiding from you all the
child labor that makes our miraculous
devices I think most Americans myself
included to it a large extent agree to
that it's a kind of complicity because
we don't want to look at the underside
of these complicated moral undertakings
it's too complicated it's too nuanced
and it's too psychologically and
emotionally inconvenient and with you
know I think you can you can find in
other sports not exactly analogous
circumstances but moral questions that
come up maybe we can say I mean you know
with the World Cup in Qatar for a decade
I talked about
corruption was how it even ended up in
Qatar slave labor and death in terms of
the building of the stadiums
um uh claims that there's going to be
kosher food but then they say then all
of a sudden there's no Kosher food and
it's based on you know the religious
perspective all these different things
and then at the end of the day I'm from
Argentina and every four years I want to
see if maybe we're going to get a win
and we finally got it and I watched the
games right I at the end of the day I
watch the games am I making
a moral trade there in some sense I mean
I guess I kind of am but it feels like
it's a different one than with football
because it's well I don't know I mean
what's different about the Qatar World
Cup thing and then saying the football's
bad for the players brains but I really
enjoy it I'm gonna watch it anyway well
I think they're the same it's the same
cognitive dissonance that and I guess
what I tried to do and against football
was not say football's dumb and brutal
and you shouldn't you know consume it
because it's misogynistic and you know
systemically racist and I didn't you
know I think those things happen to be
true and it's also a remarkable
spectacle and it's also you know what's
happening in the culture and therefore a
way to feel connected to it or you have
a personal connection to your team
um and those two things have to live
side by side and what I think the media
tries to do is sort of partition them
out and say well it's time for your five
minutes of moral contemplation in
anguish and now it's time for your three
hours of game right and I think it's
very uncomfortable when people have to
live with uh it's sort of negative
capability the two opposing thoughts
have to be held in the mind and heart at
the same time but that's like what
adults are doing all the time if they're
living you know sort of awake in some
way and I think it's partly what fox and
other propaganda Outlets are in the
business of trying to suppress they want
everything to be either or it's never
both and and so you know when I come on
the Ingram show the Chiron which I
couldn't see of course because I'm
sitting in a little van just staring at
a black dot with Laura Ingram
interrupting me in my ear but what I
what I see later on is they're um
they're trying to turn you off to
football that's what the Chiron reads
and it's just this classic how can we
make you afraid who's trying to you know
how can we exalt your grievance so that
you can hide from your own
vulnerabilities we will help you with
that and what to me is really sad is is
the sense that there isn't an
opportunity like I go on the Ingram show
and I realize we're not going to have a
serious discussion at a certain point I
go okay I'm going to take my shots here
because you're not going to actually be
in a good faith dialogue with me about
how complicated football is that it can
be beautiful and bonding and blah blah
blah and and narratively very satisfying
and at the same time that it's got a set
of values and practices that are just
inherently corrupt and that is not ever
going to be the discussion that I can
have with with her so I just we just get
into a brawl which is really just sort
of feeding the entertainment industry
that she's in but there does exist a
world or they're used to in media where
that was really literally the rule of
the fairness Doctrine said you cannot
have a single outlet that just puts out
one idea or philosophy or set of
propaganda you have to have the essence
of free speech is
um sort of different shades of opinion
reasonable opinion coming up against one
another that's what you that's the
reason I Lament The Death of the
fairness Doctrine because it created the
opportunity for somebody like Laura
Ingram or Tucker Carlson or any of these
propagandists to be challenged in real
time and to not just be able to blather
basically what I view to be kind of
brainwashing uh propaganda at Their
audience with nobody having a chance to
say hold on Laura you just said that
only certain kids the only path out for
certain Kids In America is by playing
football are you admitting that their
systemic racism in this country the
disadvantages kids of color and
especially poor kids of color it sounds
like that's what you're saying to your
audience can we have a discussion about
that as well
that's that's uh not a conversation that
is easy to imagine happening and good
faith on Fox News as you point out you
know in in terms of football
I I believe I correctly understand that
recently football ratings are down to
some degree and there are those on the
political right in the United States
that say it's because of the kneeling
and the woke and you know the stuff that
that they say about it
um do you think that the the brain
injury awareness of the brain injury
component is a factor or is it just the
fragmentation of of audiences as there
are more and more alternatives to
watching live sports that is really what
is to blame or is it hard to know is it
a combination
yeah I don't know and I I think probably
on the margins there are some people
um who were sort of marginal football
fans who have either stopped watching or
maybe cut back their consumption but
it's still the biggest thing in America
and I think the the Hamlin injury
happening at the time it did became such
a huge story because it's a Monday night
game because there's two teams really
good the ratings were really high and I
just have the feeling as I was trying to
sort of explain like football's not
going to go away because the
government's going to ban it football's
not going to go away because though the
woke mob is going to take it away that's
part of the old you know they're going
to take your guns they're going to take
your hamburgers they're going to take
God they're going to get gas stoves now
is the new one right well right it's
like this idea of if you try to make any
moral Improvement in the culture we've
got to frame it since it's the enemy of
our business interests we got to frame
it as some sort of assault on your
personal Liberty or your prerogatives or
privilege and I think football is going
to diminish in popularity only at such a
time as enough fans sort of say I think
there are other things that I can
consume that are narratively satisfying
to me that don't cause me to come up
against my own sense of maybe I'm
um rubbernecking uh people getting brain
damage and those those those wires are
really hard to connect there's a great
book that was written by a former NFL
player years ago and he said I dream of
a day in which football isn't necessary
for the American culture because I
really do think there's a direct line
between kind of the reason that America
is not able to
um put sensible gun control measures
into place the reason that our our sort
of popular culture is a wash and all
these images of violence and our video
games and our you know and football I
think there is like this underlying uh
kind of need to purge our um aggressive
impulses and to kind of consume that
violence that I think is there's a
through line there nobody wants to
connect those dots but it's not a
coincidence that most of the world
watches football that is soccer yeah and
our big sport is um you know is American
football which is just I know people try
to what about with hockey and this that
and the other and it's like okay yeah
any sport can have its dangers but baked
into to football is really big strong
fast guys smashing into one another it's
hidden underneath the helmets and the
uniforms but if those behaviors were
happening outside the context of
football it'd be like oh yeah that's
aggravated battery
is there a way to make football
safer in the sense of you know you read
about well you can have sensors and
helmets which can track cumulative sort
of impact on a player during a game and
then in theory you could pull them out
once some threshold has been reached or
you know all these different ideas on
one level it's like when your brain
changes direction that quickly doesn't
matter how thick the helmet is it's the
brain hitting against the skull to some
degree so like can football actually be
football and be be safer to the players
well it's kind of what you're saying
like when you say football you I think
what you're implying is that there's a
certain amount of risk going back to
like Cormac McCarthy's sort of saying
like what is it that we get off on and
it's basically kind of the risk the big
hit we don't want to admit it but
there's a primal sense of these guys are
putting their life on the line and why
are they lionized because they can
survive and play through injury because
there's something real that that I think
is lacking somehow in our lives probably
that's like this Primal atavistic need
to see other people play out a kind of
danger that we're insulated from so I
don't think there's any way around the
fans unacknowledged but powerful lust
for other people to risk on their behalf
I think that's just part of like modern
the the modern condition I do think that
there if there were Financial incentives
uh you know ibid the fox sexual
harassment like only you know a
corporation that makes a lot of money
only changes or a particular demagogue
like Laura Ingram they only change their
tune when they're hit in the pocketbook
the only way the NFL is going to change
their behavior is if fans change their
behavior first and there are plenty of
things that could happen as I tried to
point out like tomorrow weight limits
would be one way since these players are
now
average whatever 270 pounds well what if
they weren't bulking up in the gym and
what if in fact they were you know 200
pounds it's not going to cure it but it
would decrease the amount of impact in
the g-forces the amount those brains are
shaking around putting monitors in
helmets would create a different set of
incentives because suddenly players like
a like a pitcher with a pitch count
suddenly a player would be saying I am
not going to go in with my helmet or I'm
not going to partake in a big hit
because if I do that I'm going to be
pulled out of the game because it's bad
for my brain they don't want the fans
thinking about that again the big goal
of the NFL is to keep the dots
unconnected and they have like a willing
accomplice and fox and the right wing in
this country which essentially says
implicitly or explicitly a buffoon like
Trump says it explicitly like oh yeah
you know football it's like a man's game
now it's sissies they throw the flag all
the time what they're basically saying
is like I'm into violence I know I'm
personally a wimp who tries to get out
of the military and avoid but I'm into I
get off on watching other people be
violent right Steve last thing in the
limited time we have left you mentioned
the fairness Doctrine one of the
difficulties
I think of a reinstatement of the
fairness Doctrine now is that so much of
what we are now are consuming wouldn't
be subject to the fairness Doctrine as
it previously existed because it's on
the internet would you want to see
something specific applied to the
internet when it comes to that or is
that a different question well I I
honestly think that if you have the
power I mean the fairness Doctrine came
into being because in the early 20th
century something happened that the
founders could not have foreseen right
David what they s what happened is mass
media and some you know people in
Congress who were smart said oh my God
there's now this tool that can sway the
hearts and minds of Americans and if it
falls into the wrong hands hands that
are avaricious and only interested in
business or even worse that have a kind
of moral agenda that's inimical to
democracy that would be terrible we
can't let that happen we have to have
some form of Regulation
and people of course on the right and
greedy people freak out about that
because propaganda as you know is very
it sells right Ingram and Tucker and all
those people they are fear mongers for a
living and they make a tremendous amount
of money doing it the fairness Doctrine
said look that is
if we're going to have debates it's
important that media cover and and
participate in debates of of issues that
are publicly important but they have to
do so in a way that includes all
reasonable shade of opinion that's
what's in the Supreme Court decision all
reasonable shade of opinion now I happen
to find a lot of the outright lies and
innuendo and insinuation that that
demagogues traffic in to not be
reasonable shades of opinion but
whatever I'm even cool with having those
propagandists do their thing I just want
somebody like you or me to have equal
time to say Laura when you say that only
certain kids are going to make it
through football what you are admitting
is that America is systemically racist
against people of color and we do not
give them schools and social workers and
Economic Opportunity in their
communities what we give them is like
the the lottery ticket of maybe you can
find your way out not by the content of
your character or your intelligence or
creativity but because you're really
good at throwing a ball and getting
tackled and eventually getting brain
image for my benefit as I cost it a
little you know wimpy person sitting on
my couch getting off on the risk that
you you and that your body assumes so
like that's what I want is for people
like Tucker and Laura Ingram to stop
being such cowards hiding in their
little media silos you know plowing out
their propaganda to fear monger and
brainwash Their audience because I
really have a personal stake in this
people in my life who are important to
me or used to be important to me no
longer think in a reasonable way they've
been scared out of their wits literally
and I think it's I think a lot of
families trumpism is the symptom of this
but I think a lot of American families
would be like you know what we would be
so much healthier and our family systems
would be so much healthier if there
wasn't propaganda allowed on any side
right but especially on the right where
I think it's all about exalting people's
grievance so that people can hide from
their fears and their vulnerabilities
like the stuff that we have to solve and
work out if we're gonna solve climate
change change in inequity and the
violence that besets the culture all
these very real problems we can't do
that if we are allowing a for-profit
business allowing media to become a
for-profit Marketplace it's not it's
supposed to be a Civic institution it's
not supposed to be a for-profit segment
yeah and as a as a topic tangential to
this you mentioned the grievance
component while all at the same time
saying it's the left that has become
about grievance which is just another
instance of the projection that we're
seeing but that's that'll have to be a
topic uh for another day Steve Allman
the new novel is all the secrets of the
world you can find them on Twitter at
Steve Almond Joy Steve always great to
talk to you
hey uh David it's a delight to talk with
you and the thing about the fairness
Doctrine which we're going to finally
get restored at some point is you can
you would be fabulous I want to see a
David packman sitting in the same DS
with one of these propagandists and
saying look I do not consent to the
false narrative that you're weaving like
that's my dream